depending on who you ask Marvel's
nocturnal hero moon night is either a
mercenary an emissary of an ancient
Egyptian god an obvious Batman clone or
just an absolute lunatic over the years
countless revivals and reinterpretations
have given readers reason to think of
them in any of those ways and more as a
side effect moon nights origins and even
the core of his character can be tough
to figure out asking a question as
simple as what's moon nights secret
identity is complicated enough to make
you shake your head so to help you along
here's the truth about moon night moon
nights real-life namesake rather than
the usual hero everyman dichotomy were
used to with Superman and Clark Kent or
spider-man and Peter Parker Boone Knight
has at least three civilian names fairs
taxi driver Jake Lockley the mercenary
marc spector and millionaire stephen
graham these three identities not only
speak and act differently the people in
moon knights life choose who they
believe is the dominant persona his
girlfriend marlene for instance only
ever refers to him as Steven whether or
not he's wearing the mask co-creator
Doug much on the other hand cast moon
Knights dominant persona as Mark Specter
a name he got from an employee at a
comic shop that Monch called the best
comic shop in Manhattan at the time he
often used the names of people in his
life for new characters and as he says
one of the guys who worked there was
Mark Specter when the employee asked
when are you gonna name a comic-book
character after me Maj decided to use
his name for a new villain he was
creating for an issue of werewolf by
night with that moon Knights got a name
and the real-life mark Spectre got his
wish moon Knights villainous roots March
and artist Don Perlin first brought Moon
Knight to life in 1975 s werewolf by
night number 32 as a mercenary hired by
a clandestine group known only as the
committee to capture a werewolf named
Jack Russell now really like the
adorable terrier it was the committee
who gave Spectre his codename
his costume and even his silver
gauntlets and a truncheon specifically
designed to hurt the savage werewolf by
the end of the next issue moon knight
showed at least a hint or two of the
hero he would become while he fulfills
his contract by capturing Russell and
bringing him to the committee he also
becomes convinced that he's on the wrong
and helps the werewolf to escape it's
not all out of altruism though he made
sure to keep the Committee's money for
himself big bills break out
Bilson Kevin is known among fans for
having one of the most unique art styles
and Commons over the past 30 years he's
displayed his Scratchy innovative and
almost abstract work on books like New
Mutants daredevil Elektra and even
Batman but he began his comic-book
career drawing moonlight syncovich was
only 19 years old when he brought a
portfolio to the offices of DC Comics
but unfortunately that was exactly the
wrong time as DC was cutting loose many
of the artists who had been working
there for years still his talent was
evident so Batman artist Neal Adams won
us and Kevin says artistic influences
called up Jim shooter and said I've got
this kid fresh off the street and he
draws like me is that a problem with the
common perception that moon night was
Marvel's Batman
he fit right in alongside munch the
first Jewish superhero Monch told
Charlie Houston he made up the first
Jewish costumed hero though he also says
he didn't begin with that in mind after
learning that the real-life marc spector
was Jewish he reasoned that the
fictional version ought to be as well
whether Moon Knight really is the first
Jewish superhero depends on the number
of things including how you define the
first Jewish superhero Ben Grimm
predates Moon Knight by a decade though
he wasn't confirmed to be Jewish until a
2002 issue of Fantastic Four magneto
debuted all the way back in 1963 but his
status as a Holocaust survivor wouldn't
be revealed until 1981 similarly doc
Samson's Jewish heritage wasn't
discussed until 1990 well after the
character's debut in the pages of
Incredible Hulk so whether or not he was
the first Moon Knight was the first one
whose heritage was discussed on the page
either way it's a milestone the Hawkeye
connection Moon Knight has never been
much of a team player but in the late
80s his status as an up-and-coming fan
favorite character
landed him a spot on the West Coast
Avengers and gave them a pretty
interesting source for his
crime-fighting equipment in 1987 West
Coast Avengers number 23 the LA based
team went back in time to ancient Egypt
once there they found worshippers of the
Moon God
kunchu the patron deity who brought bark
Spectre back from the dead and charged
him to fight for justice under siege
determined to help the Egyptians defend
themselves hawkeye designed weapons for
them like darts and boomerangs the issue
ends with a cut back to modern times
where we see mark Specter finding the
same weapons his fellow Avenger design
to date we don't know if moon night or
[ __ ] you have offered Hawkeye royalties
or even just a co-creator credit if not
maybe Clint Barton should think about
retaining the services of Nelson and
Murdock for the inevitable litigation
movie night plans for an adaptation of
Moon Knight have seemed to be in the
works for years mostly on the small
screen the name mark Specter was
mentioned on an episode of the
short-lived Blade television series in
which sticky fingers from the rap group
onyx took over for Wesley Snipes
subsequently Marvel Studios partnered
with no equal entertainment to develop a
show based on the hero and once Netflix
launched their defenders series rumors
started swirling that the fist of
khonshu would fit right in with the
street-level side of the Marvel Universe
even recent Moon Knight comics have
provided an episodic psychological
thriller take on the hero that would
seem like a perfect fit for a TV show
but maybe fans have been setting their
sights on the small screen when they
should have been looking for something
bigger it's not impossible that the hero
could appear in one of the unnamed
Marvel Studios films coming up after
they wrap up phase 3 with the infinity
war sequel in fact guardians of the
galaxy director James Gunn confirmed in
January 2017 that he has an idea for a
Moon Knight film that he presented to
Marvel awesome thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]